welcome to deconstructing chatbots I'm
Priyanka Vergara and in this episode we
will learn how to integrate a dialogue
flow agent with a back-end system like a
database calendar or a CRM and each hat
part you build will need to connect to a
back-end to transfer information to and
from the business logic within dialogue
flow we are able to make that connection
using fulfillment fulfillment is a piece
of code which is deployed as a web hook
and lets your dialogue flow agent called
the business logic on a pour intent
basis during a conversation this allows
you to use the information extracted
from dialogue flows natural language
processing to generate a dynamic
response or to trigger action on your
back-end let's take our appointment
scheduler chat bot from previous
episodes and implement a fulfillment for
scheduling appointments well currently
our agent identifies the users intent of
scheduling an appointment and provides a
static response indicating that the
appointment is set up now in a
real-world scenario we need to set up
that appointment on a calendar and also
check for any scheduling conflicts which
requires us to integrate with a calendar
so let's jump into our dialogue flow
console and see how it is all set up
click on the gear icon near your agent
name to open settings locate the google
cloud project ID and click on it to open
the project in GCP console navigate to
the hamburger menu icon and locate api's
and services click on enable api's and
services and look for Google Calendar
API once you find it enabled API on your
cloud project now under the same API and
services within credentials click on
create credentials drop-down to select
service account key under create service
account key select the new service
account from the drop down and enter an
account name make sure JSON is the key
type and then click
eight in the pop-up select create
without role a JSON file will be
downloaded to your computer and you will
need this later so take note of its
location before we close it out though
copy the client email now open Google
Calendar and on the left click the plus
sign and select new calendar enter
appointment calendar for the name of the
calendar and select create calendar next
go to the appointment calendar that will
appear on the left click add people and
paste the email copied from that JSON
file then select make changes to events
in the permission drop-down and click
send at this point we are ready to go
back to our dialog flow agent and set
the fulfillment click on fulfillment and
enable the in line editor check out the
link in the description below to get the
required code for package dot JSON and
index tortillas open package dot JSON
file and copy and paste the dependencies
into fulfillment do the same for indexed
rjs as well grab the calendar ID from
the Google Calendar we just created and
replace that in index torch's
next copy the contents of the JSON file
downloaded in the service account setup
section and paste it into the empty
object service account check out rest of
the code
make appointment function contains the
responses to the user and create
calendar event function takes care of
grabbing the entities like date time and
appointment type and creates the
calendar invite it also looks for the
calendar conflicts and throws exceptions
once you're done click deploy at the
bottom of the page now we have one more
thing to do before we can start testing
click on intents and go to the scheduled
appointment intent scroll down to
fulfillment and enable web hook and save
now we're ready to test in the simulator
on the right query your dialogue flow
agent with something like set an
appointment at 4:00 p.m. tomorrow and
then respond to the follow-up queries
after getting the required information
you will see that the appointment is
added to the appointment calendar you
can verify that if you ask for another
appointment at the same time slot your
agent will respond back with an
appropriate message since that slot is
not free alright so that was a lot let's
summarize what we learned today
we enhanced our appointment scheduler
chat bot by creating a fulfillment
through inline editor enabled Google
Calendar API for the GCP project and
used those API credentials to connect
our fulfillment cloud function with
Google Calendar and finally we were able
to test our agent by creating
appointment requests on the calendar
don't miss the next episode of
deconstructing chat BOTS to learn more
of our conversational AI please like and
subscribe to our channel for more such
content
[Music]